IT'S TIME TO PLAY "AMAZON BOOK
FAIR: SELF-HELP FOR KIDS!
EDITION."
CHELSEA CLINTON'S NEW BOOK "IT'S
YOUR WORLD" IS OUT TODAY AND
IT'S BY FAR THE BEST SELF-HELP
CHILDREN'S BOOK THE CLINTON
FAMILY HAS EVER WRITTEN. MUCH
BETTER THAN "SLICK WILLY WINKY
TEACHES THE VALUE OF
SECRET-KEEPING" OR
"HILLARY BIDILLERY AND THE
CASE OF THE MISSING EMAILS."
KIDS SELF-HELP BOOKS IS A HUGE
INDUSTRY, SO I'M GOING TO SHOW
YOU ASSORTED TITLES AND FOR 250
POINTS I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME A
CHAPTER FROM THE BOOK.
FIRST UP, "MRS. GORSKI, I THINK
I HAVE THE WIGGLE FIDGETS."
>> CHAPTER ONE: IT'S PROBABLY
PARKINSON'S.
>> CHRIS: OH, GOOD LORD.
OH, DEAR LORD.
KYLE.
>> CHAPTER ONE, WE CALL IT
"WIGGLE FIDGETS" BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T PRONOUNCE "FETAL ALCOHOL
SYNDROME."
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEXT ONE, "MY BIG SISTER TAKES
DRUGS."
NICK.
>> ADVENTURES IN CRACK
BABY-SITTING.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NIKKI GLASER.
>> AND SHE'S NEVER LOOKED
BETTER.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
YOU CAN'T ARGUE WITH RESULTS,
RIGHT?
NEXT UP: "WHEN SOPHIE GETS
ANGRY--REALLY, REALLY ANGRY."
NICK.
>> CHAPTER ONE: SOPHIE, UNFOLLOW
DONALD TRUMP.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
( APPLAUSE )
>> SEE THE BACK OF THE BOOK FOR
FUN STENCIL DESIGNS TO CARVE
INTO YOUR ARM.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
LAST UP, PROBABLY THE BEST ONE,
"MY MOM HAS HEPATITIS C."
WE'RE ALL JUST CHILLING OUT IN
THIS LETTER.
NIKKI.
>> CHAPTER 3: I FEEL LIKE I
SHOULDN'T KNOW ABOUT THIS.
( LAUGHTER )
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> CHAPTER 1: WHAT HAPPENED IN
VEGAS STAYED IN MOMMY'S VAGINA.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.